（切符を受け取りください）
あっつ！あつ！あつ！あつ！
あの後さらに六本木まで移動しないといけないので
実質多分1時間半以上かかるんですよ
片道（だけでも）
それを一日行ったり来たりするだけで3時間取られるんですよ
一日の8分の1
今回東京に家を借りました
でも引っ越しじゃないです
引っ越しじゃなくて
声響くな～新居だから声が響くわ
東京に行くことが多すぎるんすよ
東京に行くことが多くて
往復するとお金がもったいないから
もうそれならいっそのこと東京で家を借りた方がいいんじゃないかという結論に至りまして
こっそり東京で家を借りる準備をしていました
静岡で今まで通りあの家はあるんですけども
東京に来るときはここに泊まります
ここでも撮影はできるので
静岡のあの部屋じゃないと撮影する気が起きなくて
それでちょっと色々忙しかったり徹夜することがあったんですけども
ま、こっちに家を借りることによって
東京にいてもこの部屋で撮影できたり
泊まったり
日帰りでしなきゃいけないことを２日間かけてゆっくりやったりできるので
結構時間的には楽になるのかなと思っております
ここが神聖はじめアミューズメントパーク東京支店です
どうだい？まだカーテンがはないから全部モザイクさ
白いとりあえず白いんすよ部屋がね
うわ！？ビックリした
エイジ：なんですか
はじめ：あれ？髪の毛赤くなってる
エイジ：染めましたよ
はじめ：なんか気持ち悪いｗ　エイジ：なんでｗ
はじめ：新居どうすか？
エイジ：新居ですか～？　はじめ：うんうん
エイジ：なんかちょっと匂いますよ
はじめ：いや～そこでしょ？　エイジ：はい
はじめ：で、俺すごい頑丈にさシールドしてあるんだよ今ほら
はじめ：なんでこんなに臭いんだろう
お互いさまなんすかｗ
キッチン広くない？思ってたより
俺ここゲーム実況部屋だよまじで
まじでここは
使わないもん　料理しないもんね
エイジ：もうしないって決めたならいいんじゃないですか？
よしじゃあここは俺決めた
ここはね編集部屋にするわ
（笑）
ここにモニターを置いて
ここにモニターも一個置いて
で、こうやって編集
はいというわけでこの部屋で撮影することがたまにあるかもしれません
多くなるかもしれません
とりあえず撮影も編集もこっちでできるのでかなり時間の使い方がうまくいけばいいなと思っております
というわけで東京編もよろしくお願いします
じゃあな！